what do you hope to achieve here with
this we hope to draw attention to what's
going on in Venezuela and they've had
you know a number of years where
literally people have died from
malnutrition babies are dying old people
are not being looked after and literally
millions of Venezuelans have left the
country to find jobs elsewhere and what
we hope is to draw attention to what's
going on in Venezuela and to get much
much needed relief supplies into
Venezuela
and we're hoping that this wonderful
happy free concert will result in the
soldiers on this bridge opening opening
the bridge and hopefully tomorrow
allowing allowing supplies into the
country it is as you know a very complex
situation and Maduro has been very
resistant why do you think you will be
able to overcome what others haven't
been able to for a month
one Guido now runs the Congress he was
selected to run the Congress and he
asked us to throw this concert and he
feels confident that he's got 90% of
Venezuelans wanting a change and and I
believe that to be the case and but we
will see what we'll see what happens
we'll see whether that whether the
soldiers do do what do the right thing
and let medical much-needed medical
supplies into the country
of getting involved in this I've met a
lot of Venezuelans who have fled the
country and they've told me the horror
stories about what's been going on in
their country I've met a lot of them
here you know heading to the concert and
talk to them and hug them and they need
help and and I'm fortunate that I happen
to have a friend in in Colombia called
Bruno a camper who I could ring up and
say look we've got three weeks to throw
a concert together by the bridge and so
that hopefully from the day after the
concert we can start getting supplies
across the border and he and his family
and friends and volunteers and the
governor and the mayor and every single
Colombian and Venezuelan here pulled
together and created this magical day
what do you say to those critics that
suggest you shouldn't be interfering in
the situation I don't think they
understand what's going on in Venezuela
and they you know there was one artist
that said that everything is great in
Venezuela nobody's suffering and you
know I'll just say you know what if
nobody's suffering why three million
Venezuelans left their country and you
know they just need they need to they
need to read you know they need to be
educated on it I think it has the chance
of being a turning point I mean it looks
like we're going to have hundreds of
thousands of Venezuelans coming coming
here today and if you if you go out into
the crowd and talk to them you'll find
that they are crying crying out for
crying out for help and you know we're
not going to stop with this concert will
be doing mostly other concerts in
America we'll keep keep keep it up until
until things change